alrighty folks well here we are and it
is time to recap the five most important
moments
of that final presidential debate
between donald trump and
joe biden so the debate was really about
whether
donald trump could somehow recast this
race obviously everybody has their
thoughts about donald trump whether they
like him or whether they hate him
this really was about whether donald
trump could number one show that he was
not going to be the guy who just ran
rough shot over joe biden that he was at
the first debate
and two it was designed to cast joe
biden in a different light and raise
serious questions about joe biden
in terms of his ability to lead the
nation in terms of his character
and in terms of his agenda for the
country and there were five
big moments for president trump along
these lines so
the first topic that was brought up by
the moderator kristin walker was of
course
covet and this is always a loser for
trump because when you're the president
of the united states and 200 000 people
die it does not matter
why it happened it does not matter
whether your actions were actually not
bad
you're going to get blamed and that is
the way that joe biden approached this
joe biden approached this by essentially
suggesting that trump was responsible
single-handedly for 220
000 deaths he suggested that if there
was an empty chair at your dinner table
it was because of this guy donald trump
and all of that happens to be
extremely false and not just extremely
false deeply immoral
when there's a pandemic that hits
everybody on the globe and wipes out
hundreds of thousands of people across
europe across asia across the united
states
across canada it turns out that that is
not due to donald trump
okay but still that is the prevailing
narrative
well trump had to draw a different
narrative and that is as we move
forward in this pandemic are we all
going to cower in our basements or
are we actually going to get out of our
basements on occasion and you know start
to live our lives and this was the
vision that trump provided i thought it
was actually a good moment for trump so
the most important moment of the debate
for trump number one
was when president trump suggested that
joe biden is basically locked down joe
that what he would like to do is lock us
all down
indefinitely in preparation for some
horrendous doom that we cannot go out
and live our lives here is trump at
drawing the contrast
all he does is talk about shutdowns but
forget about him democrats democrats all
they're shut down so tight and they're
dying
we're not going to shut down and we have
to open our schools
people are losing their jobs they're
committing suicide
there's depression alcohol drugs at a
level that nobody's ever seen before
there's abuse tremendous abuse we have
to open our country
you know i've said it often the cure
cannot be worse
than the problem itself and that's
what's happening
and he wants to close down he'll close
down the country if
one person in our in our massive
bureaucracy says we should close it down
okay and joe biden has in fact said that
he would consider
new lockdowns even though all of europe
at this point is saying yes we have a
second wave
but we are not locking down any further
so that contrast i think
is going to benefit trump because i
think there are a lot of people in the
country who are rightly cautious with
regard to covet but who are not willing
to go into full-scale lockdown
again especially given the fact that all
lockdown does is delay the spread
because once you end the lockdown it
turns out there's not really a great way
to delay the spread
much further you're seeing this in italy
right now okay so moment of the debate
number two that was very important
for president trump this was trump
attempting to draw a different narrative
about biden with regard to his actual
image for some odd reason americans tend
to believe that joe biden is honest i do
not know why this is
joe biden has been in washington dc his
entire life he was elected to senate
before he was legally
able to serve in the senate he's been a
swamp creature forever in 2008 the new
york times was reporting
about his odd relationships with people
who were
lobbyists on behalf of the credit card
industry how his son hunter was picking
up checks from companies associated with
some of those lobbyists joe biden has a
very long time been a washington
dc insider he's been the consummate dc
politician for a very long time
trump pointed this out and this is
important because again the entire media
infrastructure
has decided that trump is deeply corrupt
here was trump pointing out well you
know
joe you got some corruption issues of
your own i was put through
a phony witch hunt for three years
it started before i even got elected
they spied on my campaign no president
should ever have to go through what i
went through
let me just say this mueller
and 18 angry democrats and fbi agents
all over the place
spent 48 million dollars they went
through everything i had
including my tax returns and they found
absolutely no collusion and nothing
wrong
48 million i guarantee if i spent 1
million on you do i could find plenty
wrong
because the kind of things that you've
done and the kind of monies that your
family has taken
i mean your brother made money in iraq
millions of dollars
your other brother made a fortune and
it's all through you joe and they say
you get some of it
and you do live very well you have
houses all over the place is there any
proof that joe biden got money from any
of the members of his family no is it
true
that his family members have been making
bank off of joe biden's name for a long
time
absolutely that part is absolutely true
it is also true that joe biden's net
worth according to forbes
is now nine million dollars remember
he's middle-class scranton guy right
he's the guy who's just there public
servant no problem he's worth nine
million dollars that's
that's a lot of money so trying to draw
that contrast trying to point out that
joe biden has been a swamp creature for
a long time
i thought that that was a successful
move biden tried to redirect away from
it
and trump slapped him back into line
this was probably the best single
tactical move that trump made during the
debate there was one point at which joe
biden
tired of talking about his family tried
to redirect the conversation by directly
addressing camera and saying listen
you don't want to hear about my family
you don't want to hear about his family
you want to hear about your family and
trump was like
what is this political crap that you're
that you're spilling right now it's
pretty great
he doesn't want to talk about the these
the substance of issues it's not about
his family and my family
it's about your family and your family's
hurting badly
if you're making less than if you're a
middle-class family
you're getting hurt badly right now
statement let's get off this china thing
and then he looks the family
around the table everything just a
typical politician when i see that let's
talk about
a difficult politician okay that's why i
got elected correct
that is true and also that's very funny
because it is true there's nothing more
irritating to me in politics than when
politicians do this phony routine i was
like i know you don't want to hear about
this issue we're talking about you want
to hear
about you i remember during the
democratic debates when uh i believe it
was kamala harris did this why are we
all debating each other why are we
talking like this it's so terrible we
shouldn't be and
julian castro said uh because of debate
now whenever a politician cuts through
the crap like that it is a very good
move okay so we have two narratives that
trump has now promoted that we've gone
through
one is that joe biden is locked down joe
the other is that joe biden has
some corruption issues then trump got to
his third point
and his third point is that joe biden
happens to be a guy who's been in
washington literally forever and he's
accomplished nothing except for stuff
he's now running away from his signature
legislative proposal was the 1994 crime
bill
joe biden is now running directly
headlong away from it he talks about
you know what he's going to do with
regard to health care and public options
and trump was like well you were you're
vice president so uh how about that what
what happened this is a good point for
trump right trump says i'm an outsider
i'm getting a lot of stuff done i've
been here for three and a half years i'm
getting stuff done
you're the vice president for eight and
you're a senator for 1292 years before
that
and you got nothing done except for
stuff that you want to now run away from
here was joe biden
trying to run away from his own record
and trump saying okay so then what have
you done
for your entire life in the 80s we
passed
100 percent all 100 senators voted for
it
a bill on drugs and how to deal with
drugs it was a mistake
i've been trying to change the since
then particularly the portion on cocaine
that's why i've been arguing that in
fact we should not
send anyone to jail for a
pure drug offense they should be going
into treatment
why didn't you do it in the eight years
a short time ago why didn't you do it
you just said i'm going to do that i'm
going to do this
you put tens of thousands of mostly
black young men
in prison now you're saying you're gonna
get you're gonna undo that
why didn't you get it done you had eight
years with obama you know why joe
because you're all talk
and no action all right vice president
and then we're gonna move on to the next
section we had a republican congress
joe biden did not have a republican
congress he had a democratic congress
for the first two years of the obama
administration
the republicans didn't flip the senate
until 2014.
okay the final important moment of
debate the fifth important moment of the
debate
came when president trump decided to go
after joe biden's radicalism so biden
said a bunch of radical stuff during
this debate
he suggested at one point climate change
was going to kill us all
he also lied about obamacare he said
nobody lost their private health
insurance due to obamacare that's a lie
millions of people did
but perhaps the most obvious point of
radicalism is when
trump got biden to admit on stage that
he wants to destroy the american oil
industry this is a
pretty amazing line would you close down
by the way i would transition from the
oil industry yes
oh transition it is a big statement
because
i would stop why would you do that
because the oil industry
pollutes significantly i said here's the
deal but
that's a big statement well if you let
me finish the statement
because it has to be replaced by
renewable energy
over time over time and i'd stop giving
to the oil industry i'd stop giving them
federal subsidies
he won't give federal subsidies to the
the gas and shoot me
to the uh to uh solar and wind yeah
why are we giving it to oil industry we
actually do solar and wind
that's maybe the biggest statement in
terms of business that's the biggest
thing
because basically what he's saying is he
is going to destroy
the oil industry will you remember that
texas would you
remember that pennsylvania oklahoma vice
president biden let me give you 10
seconds to respond and then i have to
get to the final question
vice president biden he takes everything
out of context
no he did not okay and that if that
debate means anything it's going to tell
in pennsylvania
where biden's decision to go directly
after the oil industry i mean he was
walking him back within
hours after the debate said oh no we're
just going to transition i don't mean
we're going to get rid of the oil
industry
so was it a successful debate for trump
we'll find out when it comes time for
the polls but on the merits
trump did a better job in this debate
than joe biden and those were the five
biggest moments
if you enjoyed this debate recap and you
want to see more let us know down in the
comments we appreciate it don't forget
to like and subscribe